[Music]
breathless made you a star of the new
wave why do you think the French fell in
love with you they fell in love with the
character they get me instead and who is
that who is Jean Seberg million
Americans look at you and they see an
escape they want the girl from the
Midwest America's Sweetheart I've been
trying to get away from that girl my
whole life this country is at war with
itself in Vietnam the oppression of
black people in America it's the same
disgusting racism the revolution needs
movie stars Samaki just Travis for free
publicity she has a history of donations
to civil rights groups
she's a sympathizer sir I think she
could be useful you must be some kind of
crazy to come to this neighborhood in
that car was it my money you were
chasing they've tapped our phones
they're listening I can hear these
little clicks on the line I think it's
the government where have you been
I kept this late at the office our job
is to cheapen our image in the eyes of
the public there's things that I've been
ordered to do those are pictures from
our bedroom are you having an affair
they're pushing her too hard she's
coming apart this comes from above
you can't stand that I might be a part
of something more important than books
for articles or movies what are you a
part of exhibit the end of two marriages
oh is it you swing by your limousine
open your legs and your checkbook and
you think that gives you the right to
anything you want I only ever wanted to
help well that doesn't make you a better
person that makes you a tourist to
defame somebody who speaks out against
their government it's a type of
persecution you run around with a
handful of nails looking for across the
dial you deserve to know the truth
woman has her secrets
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]